US.
THE TOP OFFICIAL OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN WILL WEIGH IN ON THOSE
CHANGES IN JUST A MINUTE, BUT
FIRST TONIGHT, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ANNOUNCED
TODAY THAT THE DOJ HAS OPENED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE SPYING,
POSSIBLY ILLEGAL SPYING ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
JONATHAN TURLEY WILL EXPLAIN THE
APPLICATIONS OF THAT IN JUST A
MINUTE, BUT FIRST, THE FOX CHIEF
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT ED HENRY
WHO'S BEEN FOLLOWING THIS ALL
DAY.
>> INITIALLY, DEMOCRATS LIKE
ADAM
SHIFT LAUGHED OFF THESE
ALLEGATIONS, BUT SOME OF THE
OBAMA INNER CIRCLE AS WELL AS A
FORMER TOP OFFICIALS MAY BE
SWEATING A BIT BECAUSE THIS IS
HEATING UP NOW WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INSPECTOR GENERAL
MICHAEL HOROWITZ SAYING HE'S
GOING TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT
IT.
REMEMBER, ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS HAD SAID HE WANTED
HORWITZ TO HANDLE THIS AND
SESSIONS GOT A LOT OF HEAT FROM
SUPPORTERS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHO SAID THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
WOULD BURY THIS AND THAT THIS
WAS SESSIONS PASSING THE BUCK
AGAIN.
THIS IS A SIGN THAT HE IS MOVING
FULL SPEED AHEAD.
DEVIN NUNES FIRST REVEALED WITH
HIS MEMO, LAYING OUT HOW TOP FBI
AND JUSTICE OFFICIALS AND THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION GOT A
WARRANT FROM THE FISA COURT TO
SPY ON CARTER PAGE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, COMEY,
McCABE, AND OTHER OFFICIALS
ALLEGEDLY USED THE ANTI-TRUMP
DOSSIER TO GET THAT INITIAL
WARRANT WITHOUT TELLING THE
JUDGE THAT THE DNC AND HILLARY
CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN HAD PAID FOR
THE DIRT IN THAT DOSSIER.
HORWITZ IS ALSO WORKING ON TWO
OTHER MAJOR REPORTS INCLUDING
COMEY'S CONDUCT, PETER STARKS
TOUGH MESSAGES IN THE
UNAUTHORIZED LEAKS THE MEDIA.
THIS WEEK, THERE HAVE BEEN
CRIMINAL CHARGES FILED IN
MINNESOTA AND A SEPARATE CASE
INVOLVING A FORMER FBI AGENT WHO
ALLEGEDLY LEAKED CLASSIFIED
SENSITIVE INFORMATION, SO THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS PART OF
JEFF SESSIONS CRACKED DOWN ON
THE LEAKING OF SENSITIVE
INFORMATION, A BIG DEVELOPMENT
TONIGHT.
>> Tucker: IT SURE IS, THANKS
FOR THAT.
JONATHAN TURLEY IS A LAW
PROFESSOR AND HE DRAWS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
IT'S THE GREATEST OF ALL
CHARGES, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
POTENTIALLY SPYING ILLEGALLY ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
WHY ONLY NOW AS US BEING LOOKED
AT?
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING
PHENOMENON.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE RIGHTLY
CRITICIZED THOSE AND WANT TO
SHUTDOWN THE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION, THOSE SAME PEOPLE
OFTEN BELITTLE THESE ALLEGATIONS
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
SECRET COURT.
IT'S A DANGEROUS COMBINATION TO
HAVE A SECRET COURT THAT IS
BASED ON A STANDARD LOWER THAN
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT THAT IS
TOTALLY SECRET AND INSULATED
FROM PUBLIC REVIEW.
THAT COURT IS ALSO USED FOR
POLITICAL AGENDA.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S TRUE,
BUT WE HAVE WORRISOME FACTS THAT
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT.
WHAT I THINK IS MISSING IN
WASHINGTON IS THIS SENSE OF
BALANCE.
BOTH SIDES SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED.
THESE ARE TROUBLING ISSUES THAT
ARE RAISED BY BOTH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS.
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY IS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE GUARANTEED THAT
THERE WILL BE AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION AND HOROWITZ IS
THE PERFECT GUY TO DO IT.
HE KNOWS THE DOJ, HE'S VERY WELL
RESPECTED AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO LEARN FROM THIS PROCESS
COULD HELP US IN THE FUTURE.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD HE BE
LOOKING AT?
>> SPECIFICALLY AT THAT
APPLICATION WITH CARTER PAGE.
MANY PEOPLE MADE FUN OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE SAID
THAT HIS CAMPAIGN WAS UNDER
SURVEILLANCE AND PEOPLE LIKE
FORMER DIRECTOR CLAPPER SAID I
WOULD HAVE KNOWN IF THERE WAS AN
ORDER OF SURVEILLANCE.
IT TURNS OUT THERE WERE MULTIPLE